[Music]
hello there my name is Dr Brian Christie
I'm coming to you from beautiful
Victoria British Columbia where I'm in
the division of medical Sciences um
which is part of both the University of
British Columbia's distributed medical
program and the University of Victoria's
neuroscience graduate program and today
I'm going to present to you on a topic
that's near and dear to my heart um
concussions and we're going to look at a
new model that we've uh created to look
at concussions and uh give us a more
realistic VI view of what's going on in
the brain and it comes from a lot of
self-interest I have children that play
hockey um I ride motorcycles myself and
most of the individuals my laboratory
that you can see down in the bottom
right hand side of the slide um are also
engaged in a lot of um recreational
activities that make them prone to
having concussions so there's a lot of
self-interest in this project in my
laboratory we'll move to the first
slide and what I want to get across here
is that TBI can really vary in severity
so traumatic brain injury is caused by
any impulsive Force transmitted to the
head by an impact of the head or body
and for individuals who are engaged in
Recreational Sports like football or
hockey and even soccer you often have
about 10 hits per game game or practice
that could be considered as
subconcussive events now what we
normally focus on is those sports
injuries where somebody gets knocked out
and it's usually briefly usually less
than 30 minutes and and quite often far
less than 30 minutes and this would be
what we classify as a mild traumatic
brain injury and this is going to impair
your Global Consciousness rating
somewhat so here we have a GCS of 15 to
13 um but usually it's not accompanied
by any significant brain damage or any
morphological damage that's in contrast
to what we would call moderate or severe
TBI which are less frequent they're 15%
of all tvis and this is where you're
going to have more severe Glasco Coma
Scale ratings so 12 to less than eight
individuals are going to be unconscious
for periods ranging from 30 minutes to
greater than 24 hours and the increase
in mortality in these levels of trauma
is more far more significant now the
majority of the population is likely to
experience some form of mild traumatic
brain injury so this is where our
interest and
focuses if we look at how people have
modeled mild traumatic brain injury they
typically use procedures that involve an
open and invasive craniotomy so this is
the fluid percussion model or actually
the cortical um contusion model where
they directly impact the cortex and
there's some debate as to whether this
is severe versus moderate versus a mild
injury if you look at the um brain
sections on the lower right hand side
you can see that in almost all cases
there's some degree of injury with this
type of model and so in response to this
a lot of researchers have begun to use
more closed head injury models and
examples of this include the awake
closed head injury model that myself and
Dr Schultz in Australia have been um
working with um a pressure wave model
that
Ted alon's group at the University of
Alberta and then there's a lateral
impact model that was championed by
relle maches at the University of
Calgary that we've also been adopting
lately here and finally there's the
Chima model which is championed by
Cheryl Wellington at the University of
British Columbia and one consistent
thing about all these models is they
don't involve having a
craniotomy and most of them if they do
involve anesia involved low brief levels
of anesthesia and and the reason that we
want to avoid anesthesia is because this
in itself promotes inflammation which is
often the object of study for malatic
brain injury
models our awake closed head injury
model is a a fairly simple setup it
involves an electromagnetic
piston we have a helmet as you see in B
and this is just a uh 3D uh plastic uh
helmet that we print out on a 3D printer
um to fit the rain of of animal sizes
that we're going to investigate and the
idea of the helmet is that we can put it
over the skull of the animal and in C
you'll see that little red circle
indicates the impact point the helmet
will be over that point and it's going
to distribute the force of the blow
across the head of the animal so you
have a distributed Force blow much like
you'd have in anyone that's wearing a
hockey or a football helmet or a skiing
helmet in D you can actually see our our
full model where we have an animal
that's in a restraint cone
um and we habituate them to the
restraint cones so that they don't view
this as an aversive or stressful
environment um we put the helmet over
their heads and we actually move the
electromagnetic piston down so it's
touching the helmet and when we activate
it it's going to rapidly accelerate the
animal's head downwards 10
millimeters and then come back up very
rapidly so the animal isn't being struck
by the Piston it's having its head
rapidly moved and this G gives you the
shearing forces and centrifugal force
that you normally have whenever you
experience a
concussion so to ensure that we actually
are studying concussions we need some
form of neurological assessment tool
with humans this is often the scat or
standardized concussion assessment tool
and so for Animals we've come up with
what we call the nap score or the
neurological assessment protocol and
this involves looking at a number of
basic sensory fees features that are
likely to be affected by concussion so
for rodents we look at the startle
response and this can vary between no
reactions to a loud noise right next to
the head to the ears quickly reacting
the whole body jumping or freezing in
response to the that we also look at
limb extensions this is are they
consciously reaching out with their
limbs they can be absent or they can
reach out with both Paws to try and grab
an
object then we do a beam walk and this
gives you an idea if they're able to uh
rotate along a stationary platform um
the animals may not even attempt to walk
they can just um hang off the platform
without doing anything to moving along
with numerous foot slips um to if
there's no deficits they'll just move
along the platform um at ease gribb onto
the edges of the the thin piece of wood
with their claws and then finally we'll
do a rotating beam which allows us to
look at whether the animal can
incorporate several sensory features
they're they're moving their claws
they're moving on a a rotating surface
and again we can have the animal either
fall directly off or they can
sucessfully successfully complete this
over four times so these give us an a an
assessment of rodents what they're doing
and the students that have done this um
shown there on the right um found that
no matter how we gave this protocol we
could give this either once we could
could give it eight times in one day
eight times over two days or eight times
over four days so we can increase the
frequency and severity of the injury
across time um but what we' observe is
that with the first injury the animals
would show some level of sensory deficit
but with each subsequent injury that
level of deficit didn't increased
significantly in fact it didn't matter
how we administered the injuries we
could give them eight in one day eight
in two days or eight in four days and we
had induced the same level of deficit
and whether it was the first injury or
the eighth injury we tended to have
approximately equivalent Mo sensory
motor deficits in these animals and so
so this is a really interesting you know
Finding in of itself because it shows
that this type of injury doesn't produce
cumulative damage that may be a little
reassuring to some of you who are
engaged in hockey or um Sports where you
have incurred multiple concussions it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to have Progressive deficits with
each successive
concussion now this also goes against
what we've you know kind of learned and
so in the the next figure I'm going to
illustrate to you the cdc's view of
concussions and and we've probably all
seen this um this you know Meme or video
that's uh going to come up and we're
going to go to that next and it's going
to show basically the brain
bashing back and forth inside of the
skull producing what we typically think
of as the coup country coup
injury so let's start the
video here we see that traditional coup
Contra cou injury that many of us are
familiar with in representing that
normal injury model for concussions for
a lot of different forms of traumatic
brain
injury now if we look at this in a in a
different schematic
what we normally see is that the the top
of the brain in a rodent would be the
coup part of the injury that's up by
that TBI event little um lightning bolt
and the bottom of the brain where
there's also a little bit of red would
be the contou type of injury and what
I'd like you to consider is that there
may be a different type of injury a more
diffuse injury and we're going to call
this a center of gravity model and with
the center of gravity model the
difference is rather than having that
coup cont coup injury y we have with the
the traditional model we would have some
form of impact is going to cause the
center of the brain to move in
relationship to the outside of the brain
and so the center of Mass model would
have a more distributed injury across
the entire brain rather than those two
focal points on the coup and the Contry
coup
injury so we have a little evidence for
this and so with the the traditional
models where you actually injure the
brain with the focal you know um CCI
model or the fluid percussion injury
model you actually know whether it's
mild moderate or severe injury going
from left to right in the panel if you
look in the middle you'll see that each
one of those injury formats produces
morphological damage to the brain this
is not what you normally see in a
concussion this is not what you see in
an MRI or a CT scan of an individual
who's had a
concussion if if we look at our awake
closed head injury model what we see is
that there is no evidence for any
morphological damage on the cortex
whether you're looking from the top of
the brain or with cross-sectional
studies so we've got a model that
doesn't produce severe damage to the
cortex that allows us to look at
injuries and we also know from those
prior studies that there is a
neurological deficit following the
concussion so this is a mild
injury so one of my master students
Katie Neil looked at the distribution of
the injury and so if you look at a
normal animal and you look at newly
forming cells in the brain they only
show up in a few regions of the brain
and right in the center of this um
schema or this photo micrograph is the
hippoc cample formation you can see tiny
little black specks along it and these
are new neurons that are being formed
naturally and they are important for
learning and memory processes to occur
in the brain however after a traumatic
brain
injury we see a different distribution
and so if if you look closely at that
bottom figure you might notice that
there's kind of like salt and pepper
black spots all over the hippocampo
formation it's no longer constrained to
discrete areas of the hippocampus so
we'll blow that up a little bit so we
can see it a little more clearly and
then these are the regions we're looking
so those areas that are highlighted
represent animals that have had a
traumatic brain injury and you can see
that the area of brdu positive cells or
cells that have recently gone through
some form of cell division or
activation are not constrained to the
subgranular region which is highlighted
in White in those images on the on the
left that you see and and whether you
look ipsilateral or contralateral to the
injury you see this
distribution of amino positive cells
that extends far beyond what you would
normally expect to see in the brain and
so this is an indication that there's
actually a distributed injury in these
animals this isn't a coup Contra coup
injury because we didn't see any
distribution of injury at the top of the
brain or at the bottom of the
brain
so what's the mechanism of injury here
we know it's not that you know that
bruising bouncing around like a PE in
the
Pod that we normally used to think of as
mot traumatic brain energy but instead
it seems to be these shearing forces and
so what are shearing forces do in the
brain well they can induce damage to
vasculature first and foremost and so if
we look at normal vasculature um it
extends everywhere in the brain and
around it are microa and other gal cells
asites Etc now if we have a break in the
in the VA in the vascular chair you're
going to have something happen like a
small break and you're going to have
vascular contents emerge into the brain
parena and the Brain isn't really well
set up for damage and Vascular damage to
the brain but what does happen is that
any time you get release of these
damages Associated molecular patterns so
dams microa are going to be
activated and that means they're going
to start reorienting their dendrites and
moving towards the site of
damage and when they're there they're
going to
phagocytose these damps and take them in
so we're going to have a condition where
now we've got activated microa who are
taking up substances that are normally
constrained to the blood
vessels now the blood vessels itself are
also going to try and limit the damage
so they're going to release macras and
monocytes themselves in addition to all
these blood clotting products and red
blood cells that are normally
there now if everything healed it would
be great we would have the macrophages
and the monocytes and the Brain Parma
there wouldn't be a lot going on but if
that injury doesn't heal or sorry if it
heals we'll go back to the normal gal
state but if it doesn't heal then we're
going to have macrophases and if we had
a second injury from a second concussion
let's say now we're going to release
more products in and we're going to have
more microglia that are going to become
activated and
phagocytosed and what can happen now is
these microa can start to become
activated by fibrinogen and other blood
products and they're going to start to
release cyto
kindes so we can have il1 beta tnf Alpha
cd86 il6 Etc and these cyto kindes
normally aren't released in the brain
and so they're going to have effects on
cells of the brain and so let's look at
that and and they're going to attract
more microa which is going to exasperate
this
problem so that was fun running through
this uh those animations on this
software and I hope you bear with me the
the end result here is that we're going
to have activated microa releasing
inflammatory products into the brain
this is going to affect other cells in
the brain it's going to cause
demalation neurod degeneration and these
can lead to persistent cognitive and
emotional deficits and so so we want to
get a handle on this and this is the
whole reason for developing this
model so when we're looking at the
microvascular hypothesis the first thing
we needed to do was to stain blood
vessels with lectin and find broken
blood vessels and so we had a PhD
student W dvino perides who did this
work and he was is able to find broken
blood vessels distributed throughout the
brain here's some from the thalmus and
he's also going to show some from the
Corpus colossum and when you look at
these blood vessels they actually do
have fibrinogen around them so this is
the uh coagulating factor from the blood
that gets out into the brain
parena now this leak fibrinogen is going
to start attracting microglia and the
microglia is shown in blue here and if
we look closely we can see that there's
actually microa surround ing the
fibrinogen so this is activated miclea
is actually becoming fagio fagio cdic
and engulfing the
fibrinogen we can also see ramified
microa that haven't responded to the IM
to the injury okay so there's only
microgo that are close to the injury
here are being
activated now in other parts of the
brain like the Corpus colossum we have a
different injury pattern you can see
numerous little breaks that where we
have fibrin released in the Corpus
colossum here along this capillary and
it could be that the capillary is
actually just started releasing more
fibrinogen um because it's become less
tight so the blood brain barrier is
weakened um due to the shearing forces
but nevertheless this leak fibrinogen is
also going to be associated with microa
and so we have microa in the Cor corcom
interacting with fibrinogen so we have
two of those conditions that we talked
about with the microvascular hypothesis
we have microa interacting with
fibrinogen and we have now the capacity
for them to start releasing
neurotropins I just want to show you
another example of this um so here are
some uh you know higher resolution
pictures showing little
microblades um in the brain and they're
circled here and they show up as that
sort of purpley blue um
color and then we have our normal microa
that are distal to the
lesion we also have some activated
microG and they have all their dendrites
extending towards this fibr inage and
you can see that but interestingly we
also see something unusual we see rod
microglia and these are microa
activation states that are normally
associated with conditions like
Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's
disease so early on after a mild TR
brain inury which didn't cause
significant morphological damage we can
start to see the appearance of these Rod
micr GLA and we also of course see those
FDIC microa that I I highlighted in the
previous images engulfing fiber energy
is starting to clean up the
damage so what are those microa going to
do if they start becoming overactivated
in this area of the brain while we oh
sorry I forgot to mention that we see
this distribution pattern throughout the
brain again moving us away from that
coup cont cou injury type and more
towards this center of gravity movement
in the brain hypothesis they're shearing
forces that are causing damage
throughout the brain rather than
specific locations on the outsides of
the
brain so when we activate these microa
there's a number of things they can do
they can lead to programed cell death
they can FAS sat different products
themselves they can impact neuron
plasticity directly and they can also
engage in something called synaptic
pruning and it's this last bit the
synaptic pruning that we next became
interested in because we were wondering
if these activated microa were starting
to take away the capacity for neuronal
networks to function by reducing
spines so to examine this problem we had
to end up developing a new technique and
so Dr Patrick Nery who's helping
co-supervise one um worked with us to
look at putting very small tiny
particles of di so these are solid
particles um microscopic and you see an
a that we're going to apply in discrete
places throughout the brain we were
interested in the hippocampus so we
actually applied some
discreete little uh fragments of diet
and we would actually crush the powder
to get really tiny um dots of of diet
and apply those within the granul
celling and what dii does is it actually
gets taken up by the membrane and it
starts flowing along there so over a
period of a day to two you end up
getting entire neuronal morphologies
being stained and this has an advantage
over G in that you can dis you can get
very discret staining rather than having
numerous cells stained and overlapping
one another and when you look at the
dendrites you get Exquisite
morphological detail of their spines
and this is a publication that we uh um
recently put out by wo PR
days so when we look at how the um
spines are affected by TBI what we find
is that there are Regional differences
so in the hippocampus where we saw all
those activated microa only in the
dentate gyus did those microa have an
impact on
spines and you can see both in the
ipsilateral and in the contal side of
that dentate jarus in the lower side of
the figure we see a reduction in spine
numbers so now we have an idea that mild
traumatic brain injury even if there's
no gross morphological damage can cause
fine morphological damage at least to
spines one up from spines we be looking
at the actual dendrites that are
projecting out from cells and and that
are these spines would normally occupy
it so so let's go up a level let's look
at spines and what we found there or
dendrites and what we found there was
that dendrites were also affected by TBI
and we ended up doing something called a
sh analysis where we have concentric uh
circles placed around a cell and you can
see that in
F and then we're going to look and
measure out from there how long or how
far away from this cell body did
dendrites go and how many intersections
are there and this gives you an idea of
how complex those neurons are so if we
look at A and B normally most of us
would look and say okay B looks a little
bit more sparse it's kind of like the
Charlie Brown Christmas tree compared to
that amazing Christmas tree um you know
in a right so there's there's fewer
branches fewer dendrites and of course
now we know there's fewer spines and we
can quantify that with a sh analysis and
so if we look at the number of branches
in C we see that's reduced by the
traumatic brain injury and the total
dendritic length for the entire neuron
is also reduced significantly after
traumatic brain injury but the average
dendritic length so the amount that any
dendr coming out of that cell body um is
doesn't change so we haven't reduced the
extent of the area that the dendr can
occupy but we've reduced the density of
connections within that area and you can
and that's a way of you know actually
quantifying that Charlie Brown Christmas
tree that I'm talking about in B there's
fewer intersecting dendrites there's
fewer dendrites in the middle and we see
that plotted out in G with the blue line
representing the TBI there's less
dendritic uh um intersections so area
covered after traumatic brain
injury so what does that mean well to to
examine that we actually have to do a
functional analysis and so we use
something called field
electrophysiology in a field
electrophysiology we're going to
stimulate dendrites and in yellow and uh
representing Point number one we're
going to administer a stimulating pulse
or current which is going to give us a
stimulus
artifact that's going to lead to the
release of
transmitter that's point two and we're
going to have this little fiber volley
that um represents the activation of
those preoptic fibers when the
transmitter binds to the post synaptic
site we're going to have the next phase
which is an excitatory post synaptic
potential or epsp and that's highlighted
there in blue and we're going to measure
the initial slope of that
epsb in
blue so what does that represent well
it's going to tell us a little bit about
the size of the epsb or the strength of
synaptic connections and so at Baseline
we might get an epsp to look something
like this and if we induced ltp by
administering a high frequency burst of
stimuli we might get a larger response
like is shown in the dark black line
there and that larger response
represents an increase in the number of
Amper receptors that are available for
Activation following ltp so a way for us
to increase connections between neurons
is to have some sort of high frequency
event which increases the number of post
synaptic receptors and allows you to
establish connections or strengthen
connections between neural uh
populations and this is how we build
neural
networks now this can be a bidirectional
process and we can also deliver low
frequency stimuli and decrease the size
of these epsbs as is shown in the far
right now and you can see that black
line
epsb is smaller than the original one
and this represents the reverse we're
taking away Amper receptors or reducing
the amount of ionic flux into the post
synaptic neuron so now we can see that
we have a weaker connection and so this
allows us to look at both our capacity
to strengthen and to weaken connections
between neurons which we believe is the
basis for learning a memory
processes and so do you does m traumatic
brain injury change this
well ends up being yes and so here we're
showing injured animals in the dark gray
black colors and Sham animals so these
are animals that have been put in the
plastic bag but weren't actually hit and
we're showing their ipsilat and contella
sides and you can see in both cases
there is less synaptic plasticity or
long-term potentiation in this case in
animals that have had a mild traumatic
brain injury and this is some
preliminary data that's just in progress
and this ends up actually being some of
the weaker damage that we um were able
to
show now for that biral phase we also
can look at long-term depression and
again here's some preliminary data
showing a little bit of of a different
effect for long-term depression what we
see there is that in our injured animals
we get a very rapid reduction in our
ability for LTD so we can't reduce our
size of our synaptic responses very
easily after a traumatic brain injury
but this recovers fairly quickly within
about seven days and the way I think
about this is um after an injury we find
that um most individuals have a lot of
problems dealing with sensory input and
this could be sounds or Vision or too
many thoughts and so we often uh in
clinics ask them to withdraw from using
um their phones watching TV to go into
you know a quieter darker space to help
reduce the amount of sensory stimulation
um that they're
experiencing and this is kind of
evidence for that so these animals
aren't able to reduce the amount of um
synaptic um activity that they have in
any set of
contacts right after the injury but this
recovers with time just like we recover
with time and are able to once again
enjoy our phones and screen time
so the this uh electrophysiological
investigation is ongoing but it it's led
us to some interesting
conclusions so I'll kind of summarize
these really quickly for the end of my
time so the first thing I want you to um
you know realize is that this a weake
closed head injury model produces acute
neurological deficits very reliably and
vestibular sensory motor deficits seem
to be the most prevalent um issues that
we see in this this radent
model we can also administer this a
weake closee head injury repeatedly and
not produce gross structural damage and
I I think this is really important this
is how we are able to really mimic a
concussion that's more like what we see
in the clinical
population and when we do this we do see
evidence for microle and micral
activation and we believe that
fibrinogen may be a trigger for
microglia
Activation within the brain now these
microa have the potential to decrease
spines and our spine analysis indicates
that repeated M traumatic brain injury
actually induces deficits in spines that
are focused in the Dente gyrus versus
the coronus regions of the hippocampus
and that tells us that if we see
learning in memory deficits they may be
more uh aligned with pattern separation
deficits versus spatial navigation which
tends to be more of the ca1 region so
where the deficits occurring gives us a
hint of what types of Behavioral
deficits we might be able to
see we also see that there's
bidirectional synaptic plastic
plasticity deficits and we're further
exploring this right now but what's
important is they appear bilaterally in
the brain and this again shows us that
there's not a focal deficit this is more
of this diffuse injury model with that
Center of mass model also taken
prevalence
here and finally I think this gives us a
body of work that shows that the weight
close head injury is a really good model
to use for looking at Mal traumatic
brain injury and particularly for
looking at repeated Mal traumatic brain
injury right now we've taken groups of
animals and exposed them to repeated mot
trumatic brain injury and we're aging
them up to look at them and see how
they're going to uh function when
they're aged animals so we're going to
look at how those early injuries we
might have experienced when we're youth
engaged in football or hockey Etc might
show up later on in our lives um as we
engage in the aging process and we're
doing this um as well in a a clinical
model where we're looking at individuals
who have been active earlier in their
lives and we're looking at their uh
functional brain Imaging so MRIs in the
Aged individuals as well as do neuros
psychological assessments and doing
blood draws to see if we can match some
of the biomarkers that we expect to see
in our animal model with the clinical
population excuse me and of course all
of this work couldn't be done without a
a a cohort of amazing trainees um here
on the left you see us all at the
society for Neuroscience meeting this
year and on the right we have the entire
Laboratory um from this fall finally
able to get back together after the
pandemic and of course I need to um
acknowledge and thank our funding
agencies for supporting this work thank
you very
much